[موسيقى]
داخل أفغانستان الجديدة
في محافظة باكتيكا الريفية بعيدًا عن كابول
، دعا حاكم محافظة طالبان إلى
عقد اجتماع ، لا توجد نساء لرؤية
شيوخ القرية المحليين ورؤساء القبائل
يستمعون لصبي صغير يلتقط صورة سيلفي
، تغير كثيرًا منذ أن كانت طالبان تتولى زمام الأمور.
الهواتف الذكية ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
لكن الفقر لا يزال أكبر مشكلة في البلاد ،
لدينا الكثير من التوقعات
ونصلي من طالبان أن يقدم
[موسيقى
] في الأسبوع التالي لسقوط كابول ، قام صحفي محلي
برحلة برية لنا
لمعرفة ما كان يحدث خارج
مرشدي العاصمة طالبان  أظهر له الطريق
على الحدود ، التغييرات الجارية بالفعل ،
هجومًا ساحرًا جزئيًا يمنح التجار ما
يريدون لساعات عمل أطول
على الحدود وقمع المنتزهات التي
تفصل بين الرجال والنساء ،
دعني أخبرك قبل أن يكون لدينا
سطر واحد لكل من الرجال والنساء الآن لدينا
اثنان يتم
إبعادهما عن بعض المسؤولين الباكستانيين ، مما يسهل العلاقة الجديدة
ويدعم الفصل العنصري
في هذه الرحلة شيئين لأنهما  لقد أوضح
الانهيار المالي القريب لأفغانستان
والتحول الصعب إلى الحكم الديني الذي
اكتشف حشدًا من الناس ، أوقف الفريق أنه
محكمة إقليمية
داخل قادة محليين حريصين على الثناء
على الرئيس الجديد
الذي اعتدنا عليه أن نقطع شوطًا طويلاً للوصول
إلى محكمة طالبان كما يقول الآن  لدينا
واحد هنا ، القاضي الجديد في المدينة
وضع قانون طالبان حرفياً
تفسيرهم للشريعة الإسلامية ،
سألنا القضاة السابقين عن
كيفية عملهم ، فقالوا إنهم
يتبعون قانون الأرض وليس
الشريعة في جميع المحاكم الإسلامية في الإمارة.
الإجراءات وفقا لأحكام الشريعة الإسلامية في
ظل حكم طالبان في التسعينيات
، أدت الشريعة الإسلامية لطالبان إلى
بتر الأطراف العلنية للصوص ورجم
الزناة حتى شنقا ،
لكن في السوق المحلية ، فإن الشريعة
ليست مصدر القلق الكبير ،
حيث أن كسب
العيش أمر سيء للغاية.  لا أعرف من
هو المسؤول فقط الأشخاص ذوي الرتب المنخفضة
هنا ، ولا نعرف ما إذا كان بإمكاننا الوثوق بهم ،
فهم لا يخبروننا بأي شيء
والوضع لم يفلت من ذلك.  الأسعار المرتفعة
ترتفع
في الأعمال التجارية في المتجر ،
إنه ليس أنا فقط كما يقول ، لكن العمل
سيء في السوق ،
إنه ليس جيدًا كما كان من
قبل ليسوا وحدهم ، حيث
يعاني الصيدلي المحلي أيضًا من
المخزونات التي استنفدت بالفعل في ظل الحكومة الأخيرة
في العيادة  كانت ممرضة الأمومة
قلقة أيضًا بشأن الشؤون المالية وتقول إن الحكومة السابقة
لم تدفع لها مقابل
الأشهر الأربعة الماضية ولا يمكنها الذهاب إلى
المنزل
بالقرب من كابول طبيب آخر المزيد من
المشاكل
ليلا ونهارا يقول إننا لدينا 25 إلى 30
مريضا هل يمكننا الحصول عليها  طبيب واحد فقط
وممرضة واحدة لهم جميعًا
خارج المستشفى ، يدعي الطالبان
واقعًا بديلًا
قبل أن لا تعرف ما إذا
كان الطبيب قادمًا أم لا ، لكنهم
الآن موجودون من أجلك طوال الوقت
في هذه الرحلة.
وأجزاء من
هجوم السحر يبدو أنها تفتقد
أهم
احتياجات الأفغان لكسب الرزق الآمن